if you were watching tucker the other
night he was talking about delta they're
an airline they find running an airline
a bit boring and to be honest they're
not really very good at it
and if you're wondering why their cabin
service is non-existent
it's because most of their effort has
been focused on changing election laws
in georgia that's far more fascinating
to them than getting
you a ginger ale and a bag of sun chips
on
a long-haul flight to hawaii and these
airline execs taking a flyer winging it
on election law don't want any picture
id for voting
now delta has decided the law doesn't
meet its standards requiring voter
identification says delta
is jim crow but wait a minute you might
be wondering doesn't delta airlines
require
photo id in order to board its planes
oh that sounds like jim crow why isn't
that racist because it's not shut up
next time you fly in delta airlines it
might be fun to refuse to show photo id
and point out that it's racist to
ask you for it well what passes for the
government of the united states has
taken tucker up on that effective
immediately you don't need to show id
to fly around america on delta or united
or anything else there's just
one slight catch to be
eligible for that express check-in you
have to be a non-citizen non-resident
non-legal alien you just have to come
across the rio grande
they'll give you a covet test and
positive or negative
you get the old priority boarding for
maine or alaska
or wherever you want to go no id
required come fly
our friendly skies us citizens
not eligible tucker carlson is the host
of tucker carlson tonight on fox news
and the brand new tucker carlson today
on fox nation
and after that comes tucker carlson this
morning
and tucker carlson's afternoon tea you
won't want to miss that last one
uh tucker you you made a throwaway line
and uh the government says you know
that's a great idea
but only for people who shouldn't be in
the country in the first place
i'm laughing because this is one of
about 10 stories i know you've covered
where the government shows preference to
people who have shown
absolute contempt for our customs our
laws our system
itself and they're being treated better
than american citizens now i know
that the left and all the little
gatekeepers on twitter become
literally hysterical if you use the term
replacement if you suggest
the democratic party is trying to
replace the current
electorate the voters now casting
ballots with new people more obedient
voters from the third world
but they become hysterical because
that's that's what's happening actually
let's just say it that's
true if look if this was happening in
your house if you were in sixth grade
for example and without telling you your
kid your parents adopted
a bunch of new siblings and gave them
brand new bikes
and let them stay up later and help them
with their homework and gave them twice
the allowance
that they gave you you would say to your
siblings you know i think we're being
replaced by
by kids that our parents love more and
it'd be kind of hard to argue against
you because
look at the evidence so this matters on
a bunch of different levels but on the
most basic level it's a voting rights
question
in a democracy one person equals one
vote
if you change the population you dilute
the political power of the people who
live there
so every time they import a new voter i
become
disenfranchised as a current voter so i
don't understand why you don't
understand this i mean everyone wants to
make a racial issue out of it ooh the
you know white replacement there no no
this is a voting rights question
i have less political power because
they're importing a brand new electorate
why should i sit back and take that the
power that i have as an american
guaranteed at birth
is one man one vote and they're deluding
it no they're not allowed to do that
why are we putting up with this well
that
it's particularly interesting if you
take small states like vermont for
example
which has got a little more than half a
million people
they're basically uh being
the equivalent you use the word
replacement but they're basically being
rendered irrelevant
just by the sheer numbers uh coming over
the border in the course of any one year
so if they if the
democrats get their way and abolish the
uh
electoral college vermont and wyoming
and all kinds of other states
simply don't matter at all what i don't
get tucker is
why are people put up with this is it
just because of incompetent
framing of the issue by republicans
it's because of highly competent framing
by the democrats they have framed
immigration as a racial issue so any
complaint
about immigration is a complaint born of
racism
you're a racist if you're against it but
as far as i'm concerned
it doesn't really have much to do with
race actually i mean this is people from
a bunch of different
countries and cultures most of them are
latin but within latin america anyone
who's ever been there can tell you
there's a huge range of people
and of subcultures like it's not as
simple as they pretend it is
but it really is much deeper than race
race is a factor for some people
but underneath it all it has to do with
what kind of country you want to live in
and how much political power you have by
the way i will never understand as long
as i live why the so-called black
leaders maxine waters people who claim
to speak for black people
are sitting by and allowing black
political power to disappear
like so in a generation i really don't
think
that ma whoever replaces maxine waters
and compton is going to be listened to
by anybody because as a numerical matter
it just won't matter
okay so african americans who by and
large have been here for 400 years your
ancestors were taken here
400 years ago they will have no say in
how the country runs because as a
mathematical question it just won't
matter
no one wants to say this out loud but
it's true and it has nothing to do with
race it has to do with
the people who live here are being
disempowered
by a new group brought in without their
consent by a political party that cares
only about political power
if you frame it that way i think
everyone can kind of wake up and realize
what's happening
yeah and you're absolutely right the the
black americans will be the first
victims of this and they will be
rendered demographically
irrelevant and they'll wonder and
they'll suddenly figure out oh all this
uh
georgia jim crow talk is uh it was
actually just a cover for something
entirely different
exactly that is that's what it is
and so when the gap or coca-cola which
by the way is given type 2 diabetes like
half the black population but leaving
that aside
when they get up they're like oh black
lives matter you know we love black
people etc
they're actually supporting an
immigration agenda
that eliminates black political power
that's just true and i don't again i
don't know why
it's so obvious even i can see it and
why is no one saying this
yeah yeah and you're quite right on on
the diabetes too the underlying
condition
for a lot of this covid is coke uh thank
you
uh thank you for that uh taco will be uh
watching uh
tucker carlson today you've got a lot of
subjects subjects of the crown
on that show but you do let an american
citizen get in there once in a while but
a lot of british subjects on it
interesting thank you